la situation
dans le donbass est très préoccupante
ces dernières heures il y a déjà eu
apparemment plusieurs victimes et je
veux avant tout avoir une pensée pour
les personnes et les familles qui ont
été touchés et de manière très claire il
y à des actes qui se sont multipliées
ces actes à nos yeux doivent cesser ils
contreviennent
aux accords qui ont été pris au cessez
le feu
respecté jusqu alors et pour lequel les
l'ensemble des parties prenantes avait
réitéré encore récemment leur adhésion
on va là président français qui avait
aussi appelé au dialogue pour une
solution mais nous n'avons pas de preuve
les déclarations de vladimir poutine sur
le retrait de ses hommes dans dans cette
région de la frontière avec l'ukraine
gauthier rybinski bonjour à vous on va
tenter d'analyser ce qui se joue en ce
moment même dans le donbass à l'est de
l'ukraine et puis faire sens avec ses
déclarations du président français vers
quoi on s'achemine là dans les
prochaines heures on sait que le
président américain tient notamment une
réunion le visioconférence a à ce sujet
qu'est ce qui est en train de se jouer
d'un point de vue diplomatique d'abord
vous avez vu ces derniers temps ce de
notamment cette semaine la manière dont
les uns et les autres font monter la
rhétorique c'est aussi une arme la
rhétorique en entend de entendre conflit
est temps que la guerre n'est pas
déclarée
l'atout des américains consistait
justement à dire de manière la plus
ouverte possible les dangers qu'ils
étaient en cours et les risques qu'ils
étaient en cours et on a bien vu que les
russes avaient été fortement agacé voire
horripilé par cette rhétorique là en
disant mais enfin qu'est ce que c'est
que c'est fou on parle d'hystérie
occidentale qu'est ce que c'est que ces
fous alors que nous nous sommes en
dessous et c'est là la tactique de
poutine qui est intéressante c'est
lorsqu'il se présente comme étant le
chef d'état responsable
qui n'est pas un va-t-en guerre et qui
au contraire a dans l'idée une façon de
résoudre le conflit c'est comme ça qu'il
reprend la main
donc la question des bombardements
aujourd'hui elle et elle rejoint
finalement ce qu'est le but de guerre de
vladimir poutine ou le but de conflit ce
qu'il a particulièrement agacé également
c'est que l'occident a fait de cette
crise un problème entre la russie et
l'ukraine or pour la russie le problème
il est beaucoup plus vaste c'est dans
son rapport avec l'otan avec l'occident
et donc quand vous avez aujourd'hui ces
bombardements il faut être prudent
vis-à-vis de ces bombardements parce
qu'il ya toujours depuis 2014 d d d d
comment dirais-je des escarmouches entre
les deux entre craignent un
effet loupe en ce moment bon je peux me
tromper level des heures qui passent
peuvent affirmer ce que je vous dis mais
il faut être prudent là dessus
simplement il faut toujours voir que
lorsque vladimir poutine demande
beaucoup beaucoup c'est à dire quelque
chose qui irréalisable là le nom
élargissement de l'otan ça veut dire
qu'il peut se contenter de quelque chose
d'intermédiaire quelque chose
d'intermédiaire ça serait quoi ça serait
le donne basse ça serait le dôme basse
où ils interviendraient au motif de la
défense des russophones et vous souvenez
que quand il a parlé avec le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz il a parlé d'un
génocide qui est un terme à la fois
exagéré excessif et même scandaleux
quand on sait ce qu'est un génocide et
donc lui considère qu'à partir de là il
pourrait intervenir sans même
reconnaître les république fantoche mais
de pouvoir être présent et de tailler
des croupières et de fêtes d'amoindrir
l'ukraine danse à son intégrité
territoriale pour faire en sorte que
cette ukraine soit définitivement ou
pour longtemps qu'elles soient décrochés
ou qu'elle n'ait plus envie d'avoir des
aspirations à l'otan parce qu'à ce
moment là il y aurait d ignorer sur son
propre territoire gens qui seraient
capables de pas de s'y opposer et de
manière très ferme et c'est comme ça que
le dire poutine avant ça veut dire aussi
que peut-être dans ce cas de figure il
n'y a pas un coup pour vladimir poutine
est peut-être le coup à jouer dans cette
partie actuelle et qu'on peut voir aussi
deux trois quatre coups plus loin qui
peuvent être aussi
quelque chose qui le sert dans sa
volonté finalement de ne pas laisser la
démocratie
ganga l'année son univers russe et à
partir de là évidemment il aurait
atteint son but parce que sinon sur le
plan militaire
strictement stricto sensu personne ne
menace elle admire petite personne
menace la russie militairement c'est
simplement politiquement qu'il y à un
vent possible de démocratie qu'il a
serait comme un appel pour les russes
qui peut être en en rêvent encore dans
des aspirations à cela et qui verrait
que dans les marges de l'ancien empire
on y accède et qui voudraient aussi
qu'au sein de la russie ça soit le même
cas est-ce qu'ils envoient pas aussi un
signal lorsqu'on sait par exemple qui se
prépare à mener des exercices de grande
ampleur alors qu'il y a trois jours à
peine justement le kremlin a annoncé la
fin d'une partie de ces manoeuvres il
fait quoi il montre les muscles il agite
la menace constamment pour dire je vais
me retirer je recule mais en même temps
attention ça peut partir à tout moment
oui c'est à la fois lindsay est à la
fois parce que je vous disais reprendre
la main dans cette rhétorique galopante
et et grimpantes et d'un autre côté dire
au fond que s'il y avait un conflit
quelle que soit son ampleur il n'en
serait pas à l'origine ils n'en seraient
pas responsables qu'ils ne feraient que
répondre à une demande par exemple des
russophones n'oublions pas que dans le
dos de base beaucoup de personnes se
sont vu distribuer un passeport aux
russes ce n'est pas tout à fait la même
chose vous avez des gens qui se
reconnaissent comme riche mais qui parle
l'ukrainien là il s'agit de russophones
ayant reçu un passeport russe et
attention ce qui aurait voulu refuser ce
pas ce passeport russe aurait eu des
ennuis nous dit-on d'après des
témoignages assez précis donc voilà la
manière pour bladimir poutine c'est de
créer quelque chose qui serait un bon
prétexte tout en le préservant lui de la
responsabilité lui pourrait dire
jusqu'au dernier moment j'ai fait tout
ce qu'il fallait pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de conflit merci beaucoup merci pour ces
éléments de compréhension